This amoeba is making its home out of a drop
of water, taken from a larger sample and then
sandwiched between a glass slide and a coverslip
before being placed onto a microscope, oh
so carefully.
And perched above, is us, peering down through
the lens to see a magnified version of its
daily life.
And coming from underneath the slide is white
light, often passing through microbial bodies
so that they appear transparent, like moving
outlines.
But white light is a fracturable thing, made
up of different wavelengths that can interact
in their own particular ways with the world
they encounter, absorbed by some materials
and reflected by others.
For wavelengths that lie in the visible spectrum,
that reflected light gives us color.
Like the inside of this ciliate, its clear
body rendered kaleidoscopic following a colorful meal.
We often link color to perception: how we
see it, how it makes us feel, how we pick
and choose our favorites.
Colors signal, not just like traffic lights,
but in nature.
Feathers that attract, bright markings that
warn, and patterns that camouflage.
But setting aside our own voyeurism, there
are no complex eyes on you when you’re microscopic.
The colors that emerge are entirely incidental,
in a sense stripped down to their fundamental
natures: the product of light absorbing and
reflecting at different wavelengths, these
colors do not exist to communicate or signal,
they’re just the color they are, and when
we find beauty here, it’s not because there’s
any advantage to that beauty, it’s just luck.
Maybe the easiest color to translate from
what we see on a daily basis to what we observe
under the microscope is green, the color of
photosynthesis, and thus of many plants and
photosynthetic microbes.
This is, of course, not a coincidence, but
a monochromatic pattern of evolution and endosymbiosis,
the product of an ancient cyanobacterium that
made its home in a plant and brought the green
pigment chlorophyll along for the ride.
When light hits chlorophyll, the molecule
absorbs energy from the red and blue wavelength,
exciting electrons and powering the reactions
that produce storages of chemical energy.
What remains to the observer, to us,  are the green
wavelengths that reflect.
Other photosynthetic microbes rely on chlorophyll
as well, sometimes containing different forms
of the pigment that allow them to access other
wavelengths of light.
While chlorophyll is essential to cyanobacteria,
the “cyano-” in their name implies another
important color: blue.
This is the product of phycocyanin, which—combined
with chlorophyll—gives the organisms that
color that makes them often known as “blue
green algae.”
Phycocyanin is an accessory pigment, it’s
nature’s way of hedging its photosynthetic bets.
Relying strictly on chlorophyll, after all,
would restrict what kind of light an organism
can take advantage of.
For cyanobacteria, this can be particularly
problematic if that light gets absorbed by
water or by other organisms above them.
So it relies on assemblies of phycocyanin
to absorb additional wavelengths, creating
alternate sources of excitation energy for
photosynthesis.
But there are, as always, exceptions
Other microbes use a class of molecules called
carotenoids as accessory pigments, which bring
pops of yellow, orange, and red.
Like chlorophylls, these are a type of chemistry
that we’re familiar with from plants and
vegetables we see everyday, like the orange
carotene of carrots.
Translate them into the microbial world, and
you get diatoms like this one, its beautiful
golden brown color derived from the carotenoid
fucoxanthin.
But carotenoids can serve other purposes,
like the red pigment astaxanthin, which we
see on a more regular basis in the pinkish color
of shrimp.
The most plentiful source of astaxanthin is
this microscopic Haematococcus, which we found
in a cemetery birdbath.
When conditions are good, the Haematococcus
is green.
But if the sun becomes too intense or nutrients
become scarce, they form protective cysts
and produce large amounts of astaxanthin,
which shields the cells from harmful ultraviolet light.
These cysts are almost indestructible, valiant
against chemical and mechanical attempts to
break them until conditions return to normal,
allowing the Haematococcus to do the same.
Euglena sanguinea use astaxanthin to protect
themselves as well, rapidly reddening in response
to large amounts of light to protect themselves
from the dangerous rays of the sun.
These pigments have implications beyond their
microbial uses or even their visceral beauty.
Scientists have converted pigments like phycocyanin
into a fluorescent tool that allows us to
map out the interiors of other cells, and
Haematococcus and diatoms are objects of study
for the potential health benefits their carotenoids
may confer.
Their colors are observed and utilitarian
in our hands, guiding and identifying and
indicating.
Earlier, we stated a simple premise of the
microcosmos: that its inhabitants live in
a world largely unobserved.
We made that statement while casually setting
aside the obvious: that you and I, we are
here, watching these microbes, both colorful
and not.
They did not evolve to be seen, in fact we
went almost our entire history without ever
seeing one, but now they have certainly captured
our attention.
These colors developed long before we were
around to notice them, independent of our
preferences and our needs.
But we have bodies and minds that have evolved
to take note.
Even the examples we’ve highlighted today
emphasize our own observational bias, focusing
on wavelengths that are visible to us as a
species even while light extends far beyond
that spectrum.
Color is, to us, often subjective, but it’s
a product of light of physics and of chemistry
that has impacts at all scales.
Even if the way we process it varies, the
underlying physics does not.
What the microcosmos helps us understand is
that there is more to color than what we see,
that our perception of it is only one facet
of what it means to live in an illuminated world.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
Journey to the Microcosmos is a production
of Complexly which is a company that makes
stuff for youtube and right now at Complexly
we’re trying something really new.
We’re trying three new things.
It’s a pilot season.
We’re launching three brand new shows, each
on their own channel and each will run for
three episodes.
And then we’ll decide if any of those will
continue on.
Now, we love all of these ideas but we can’t
make all of them happen so we’d love your
feedback and what you think should continue.
Please check them out and share your thoughts
And thank you to all of these people who support
this channel on Patreon so that we can continue
making these very cool videos.
If you’d like to join them, and we would
love it if you did, you can check us at Patreon.com/journeytomicro.
And if you want to see more from our Master
of Microscopes, James, check our Jam and Germs
on Instagram.